Lauren I'm not in the I'm not in a
joking mood good Oh me someone's not in
a joking mood nope not today it's all
seriousness from here all right nice
nice
hey guys I'm Ryan right [ __ ] I win
I immediately lost we're gonna watch the
season 5 trailer of The Walking Dead I'm
excited to see this part for you you saw
par 4 right
season 4 yes I see now all of them the
owl of them yes the correct usage of the
word owl I [ __ ] I love The Walking
Dead and the way the last season ended
was pretty [ __ ] cool so good who's
your favorite character Michonne
Michelle she's pretty [ __ ] seriously
if I wasn't in a zombie apocalypse I
would want a sword that would be my
weapon of choice I would probably be the
best choice that makes it just makes the
most sense it does it doesn't make noise
right so once I want to track a young
piano right exactly you just slice their
head off and their [ __ ] [ __ ] yeah
really easy stuff yes I'm still
personally more of a Rick fan yeah I
love Rick he's just kind of little bit
crazy I know but who's your least
favorite least favorite who's currently
on the show right now that's my least
favorite I'm trying to send you like
mental I'm sick I'm trying to like this
is what you're doing supposed to give me
a clue yeah I don't know okay you read
my mind
Karl is my least favorite yeah Karl can
be pretty [ __ ] annoying so annoying
be an annoying little [ __ ] ah why is he
dead I know Rick should beat that like
15 year old kid of his just beat him so
Jenna speed has beat him who cares what
is gonna go to jail for it Daryl's also
pretty sweet gerald my second thing like
if I had to choose a person to to go
through the absorb a apocalypse with it
would be Daryl yeah for sure I like how
the two most badass ones were the two
most emotionally closed off ones that's
why they're so badass yeah that's the
goal to being badass and close off your
emotions medieval I'll do that and I'll
finally be mysterious and intriguing to
you you know sometimes that works guys I
mean girls love apples
right right right I can be I'll stop
being an [ __ ] to you [ __ ] clean up
my apartment yeah
now working now let's watch this video
one two three
me yeah it's already okay I'm ready to
to screw with the wrong people
I just hope you understand that we
didn't hurt you
nothing was personal
you don't have to do this we can put the
world back to Olive us you have a man
here's the cure we just have to get him
to Washington you just have to take that
chance
[ __ ] them up you don't have a choice oh
you
you join us and go to Washington and
cure this thing
we get to start over all of us not
splitting up again we don't know what's
coming next we get to Washington we will
make the Dead die and the living will
have this world again
I don't trust this guy
baybel concept
you don't trust us anymore
these people are not family and if you
hurt them in any way I will kill you
I certainly to me for DC right now
I'll going anywhere without people
you sure three of us are go
you know what is it standing
my lady says
no matter what you think
are not safe
he's so badass every sacrifice we make
needs to be for the greater good in here
you're not the greater good you're part
of a system oh Jesus
well she's still alive meanwhile this
character is doing this wow that looks
awesome
you know it what's exciting to me is
like my favorite season so far has been
season three but there was a lot a
season three what happened in two that's
the one where there's like that town and
the governor oh yeah okay yeah that one
was my favorite season so far but there
was a lack of zombie focus and I feel
like this season's gonna have human and
zombie focus but here's the thing with
the show there's only so many humans
fighting zombies things that you can do
that's why they have to bring in the
governor they have to have terminus they
have it's it's more about the people and
and how they're dealing with this crisis
over them killing zombies no exactly but
at the same time like there's something
about it where season three was just
about the human and protagonist
antagonist and I felt like we kind of
forgot about the zombies and the zombies
to me are like you know that's part of
the that's like the cherry on top of
this whole show right that's true I
don't I didn't know anything about what
this season is gonna be about and I
wasn't expecting it to be them going to
DC I thought it was going to be a
struggle in terminus so that's really
exciting because then that would be like
the same thing of like than finding a
governor than fighting - so there yeah -
okay I know that one guy's a scientist
and how he's he's the one person that's
gonna save us all but like why doesn't
he at least like try to write down what
he knows or tell other people what he
knows so just in case something happens
to him cuz that sounds like a better
plan to me well I think that's the
information that's kept him alive though
is that he only knows and it's like in
this day and age humans are willing to
just kill you like savages - so I think
like that
if he dies then the information is dead
with him I mean Lauren you do make a
good point
thanks but I'm just trying to understand
where he might be actually a funny
feeling situation there's no need to
raise your voice there's no need to get
mad at me okay not mad at you oh hey hey
hey hey I'm not accusing you of anything
I'm just saying let's not go down this
path I like being friends with you it's
not ruin it over the walking dead okay
what's her face with the blonde hair
that they should amend though the
daughter a daughter of Maggie's sister
IU sister Jillian I don't know she's a
[ __ ] [ __ ] drove off and left Darryl
[ __ ] no I have a choice that pissed me
off you gonna wait it a little [ __ ] she
was kidnapped she was kidnapped
yeah she didn't drive off on her own I
thought she drove off on her own
Wow kidnapped her we don't know those
people in the hospital obviously they
kidnapped her I thought she might have
just found me no no I'm pretty sure that
she was like stuffed in the trunk and
was kidnapped I don't remember any of
that means yeah comment below and tell
us who's right and obviously she was
like in love with Darryl so why would
she just drive off I'm pretty darn sure
she was kidnapped and then there's those
crazy people that she's in the system
and whatever they said so that's really
exciting because they have didn't show
her all the rest of the last season so I
was wondering what happened to her
mm-hmm and now we'll find out we will
find out mm-hmm so yeah I mean this is
really just speculation talk guys we
can't know for sure yet ya know for sure
yet there's so many short clips and
we're trying to obviously figure out
what's gonna happen what they're
probably doing is trying to mislead us
so they can surprise us later I hope so
I like I like it when they do that hey
guys if you're new to the channel you
can subscribe here to the real rejects
and Lauren has a channel to where for
some reason she's been giving a lot of
dating advice that's so odd girl to give
dating advice any anything we can talk
about anything it doesn't have to be
dating it doesn't have to be dating
advice but let me just say this real
fast you know if you want to learn to
become a millionaire you gotta talk to a
millionaire so if you want to learn how
to get a hot girl yeah listen to
girl that simple damn promotion that's
what I just did alright so yeah
subscribe to my channel then yeah hey
Lauren let's do some shout outs oh we're
getting shout out we're just gonna shout
out some people who've been
complimenting Lord and some people who
also I'm sure that's because it makes
you really sad whenever I come here and
Ryan's like we're gonna do some shout
outs and he pulls up this list of people
requesting shout outs from other girls
on the channel well I got at least 11
requests 11 for me yeah boy or at least
they're saying that you're like their
favorite and stuff Jacob pass SEC PAP
check fat check tasting this homeboy
said Lauren's my favorite you're my
favorite
oh let's hope not everyone says they're
your favorite or else you're gonna have
a lot of favorites margaret's they're
gonna have a competition we should have
a competition
oh who likes Lauren the most ready to
the - Jacob you're I'm rooting for you
buddy
because you got the first shout out so
I'm rooting for you you keep climbing
that ladder Jake slacker Lauren what's
wrong with you
that was [ __ ] hilarious it was the
funniest joke I have made on this
channel ever that means you make
terrible jokes what why I bring here I
don't know all you do is put me down
consistently I've done nice things for
you and you just put me down all the
time that's the relationship that we
have that's what makes me keep coming
back for more
advice to the girls no just whatever
guys like being treated like [ __ ] thanks
Tristan point especially during sex
Reapers anime reaction we did a fifty
Shades of Grey trailer reaction and he
said he loves me and Lauren yeh
represented a reaction represented me a
reaction we love you too
we love you too from my heart to yours
look at that your hearts flying how's
the hard flying I don't know oh my god
did you climb Jacob's Ladder I brought
it back :
I brought it back and even a reaction
forgot about you there for a second do
love you
you stay classy and wear a condom when
you have sex that's a good idea
Joshua Jones Oh Joshua
yeah you're gonna read that out loud I'm
gonna read this whole thing alright I
want to read it like how I think he
sounds you'll run hmm you're awesome
Lauren you're hot and cute though I've
been having a thing for Asian girls
I guess cuz I'm half Korean athletic
anyway give me the shout out please all
right
I bet that was spot-on spot-on but Brian
is awesome and Lauren is hot and cute he
has a thing for Asian girls dude
you should consider this guy go on
Laurens Channel five most attractive
qualities in a guy make sure you can
meet most of them how many would you say
three out of five four out of five let's
go four out of five four or five does it
make sense you want all of them do you
really think you'll find the real olam
well I should hope so that's what I
don't think that anybody should settle
for a lesson but nobody's perfect
nobody's perfect but I think that people
can be perfect for each other you just
blew my mind
that is what you have done Joshua thanks
for leading us into that buddy without
you we wouldn't have gotten there
well thanks Joshua I bet you're hot and
cute too
Oh Lauren said that about you I've been
trying to get her to say something a
little bit like that to me for like six
months now not even right here the
motion has curly hair mo she said is
you're not a bad-looking guy the truth
it Thanks we're done